hey 42 here
on the 17th of November 1961 a young
American man vanished in what was then
Dutch New Guinea after an arduous
investigation the authorities deemed
that he'd drowned after his boat
capsized a few clicks off the coast of
the town of a gas in the arafura sea
his remains were never recovered
intriguing kind of but strap yourself in
because two crucial details transformed
this tepid tale into a scintillating
Saga first the man who went missing was
Michael Clark Rockefeller son of a
future vice president and great-grandson
of one of the richest men who ever lived
and second contrary to the official
report Michael Rockefeller didn't drown
in the Autumn of 1961. rather he was
eaten by cannibals
to tell his tale we must travel to far
away Frontiers unlock the secrets of one
of the planet's most secluded tribes
unravel a governmental cover-up that's
lingered for decades and confronts some
unpalatable truths oh and stick around
to the end because this one has a truly
spectacular twist
from birth Michael was bathed in
privilege New York was his playground a
world of luxury and abundance spending
his days beside future Titans of
politics and Industry at some of
America's most acclaimed academies he
graduated from Harvard in 1960.
the powerful pedigree of Michael's
family propelled his academic Ascent but
he wasn't just some spoiled Silver
Spoons Scion he boasted big brains as
well as his big bankroll with the world
at his feet and the Rockefeller Legacy
to uphold his path seemed set in stone
but first Michael yearned for an
adventure
[Music]
The Rockefellers had always been
admirers and patrons of Fine Art
Michael's grandmother founded the famous
Museum of Modern Arts in New York and
his father Nelson had a particular punch
on for what was then called primitive
art non-western artwork crafted by
indigenous peoples around the world in
1954 Nelson founded a gallery in which
to Showcase his passion
no force in the universe Rivals a son's
desire to make his father proud and what
better way for Michael to achieve this
than to curate a collection of global
wonders for his father's new Gallery in
1961 Michael Rockefeller departed for a
daring art Gathering expedition to Dutch
New Guinea home of the Asmat an ethnic
group almost unknown to the Western
World at the time visiting the azmat was
like taking a time machine back to the
Stone Age when Michael turned up they
had no textiles or metals they hadn't
even invented the wheel but whilst they
weren't too clued up on Tech they were
masters of arts and crafts even today as
Matt wood carvings are highly sought
after by collectors don't get the wrong
impression though the Asmat weren't some
quiet tribe of Master Craftsman who
wouldn't say boo to a New Guinea Goose
when they weren't whittling wood they
were Waging War either that or in
engaging in their favorite pastimes of
head hunting ritual cannibalism and
Monopoly their way of life was a far cry
from the silver spoons and skyscrapers
Michael was used to but he was
undeterred in fact he threw himself into
this passion project with purpose and
Panache Michael's diary entries from
this time reveal a man entranced by the
strange new world into which he'd
stumbled for six months he lived amongst
the Asmat studying their way of life and
procuring art for his father's Museum
here masked An Almighty collection you
can still see most of it today in the
Michael C Rockefeller wing of the met in
New York which is all very lovely but as
you already know this story doesn't have
a happy ending
Michael was traveling with
Anthropologist Renee vassing and their
two local guides when a wave capsized
their boat three miles from Shore
with no com's equipment on board the
guides swam to get help whilst Mike and
Renee stayed with the stricken vessel to
begin with they weren't especially
worried but they were steadily drifting
further from the shore and after 24
hours with no sign of rescue Michael's
patients wore Finn the guides had
clearly abandoned them and with each
passing second the swim back to safety
stretched out before them he stripped to
his boxer shorts tied a couple of empty
Jerry cans around his waist and struck
out for sure
now the question that's fascinated
historians and amateur sleuths ever
since is simple
what happened next
for any vassing that question has a
brief answer
he stayed with the boat and was rescued
by the Dodge a few hours later their
popping guides had sought help as
promised but state had to trudge through
several miles of mudflat mangroves and
mosquito infested forests after swimming
ashore as for Michael he was busy
turning himself into a modern day myth
thank you when word of his disappearance
reached the Rockefellers in the U.S they
used their plentiful political and
financial leverage to launch the largest
Manhunt in the history of the South
Pacific involving thousands of locals a
multitude of ships helicopters and
spotter planes Michael's father and twin
sister flew to Dutch New Guinea to
personally oversee the search
despite this Monumental effort no trace
of Michael was ever found
and after 10 fruitless days the
Rockefellers returned home
The Manhunt was officially called off
two weeks later and Michael was declared
legally dead by drowning in 1964. at the
time his estate was worth 660 thousand
dollars about 7 million today not bad
for a graduate ever since his
disappearance there have been doubts
about the official version of events
it's generally assumed that reny and
Michael were between 10 and 14 miles
offshore when Michael abandoned the ship
that's a hell of a swim in open water
but it certainly isn't impossible don't
let Michael's unassuming appearance fool
you as a university Varsity wrestler and
former Soldier he was tough as Nails he
was also a supremely strong swimmer had
rudimentary flotation aids with him and
perhaps most importantly of all he was
fighting for his life
people can achieve incredible things
when failure means certain death just
watch squid game it's intriguing that
despite the scale of the search effort
Michael's body was never found a drowned
man roped two Jerry cans should float
but nothing surfaced
the local Wildlife is often blamed for
this conundrum hammerhead sharks and
saltwater crocodiles infestes Waters but
shark attacks are practically unheard of
in the area and whilst the Colossal Crux
pose a threat they're notoriously messy
eaters if one did get him there would
have been a few chunks left over in the
years after Michael fell off the map
several people attempted to replicate
the swim he would have been faced with
in 1961 and all of them made it to the
shore alive it's for that reason and
others I'll come to in a minute that
convince many he was still out there
amongst them was Milt Macklin the
renowned editor of an adventure magazine
called Argosy
in October 1968 Macklin was visited by
an Australian Smuggler who claimed to
have new information about Michael's
disappearance little did he know that
his information was about a melt milled
Macklin's mind
try saying that five times quickly this
was 1968 remember seven years since
Michael disappeared and yet whilst
visiting a remote Highland off the east
coast of New Guinea 10 weeks prior The
Smuggler claims to have seen the Lost
Rockefeller with his own two eyes
now Milt Macklin was an ex-military man
Explorer and a master of the mustache
but Above All Else he was a journalist
who knew how to sniff an exclusive scoop
soaked he packed up his life in New York
and chartered a course for New Guinea
however the first leg of his journey
proved fruitless he visited the islands
The Smuggler had told him about only to
find it deserted with no signs of
habitation
but Macklin hadn't flown nine thousand
miles to get TK owed when the first
hurdle smacked him round the head
especially since he'd noticed a curious
trend
nobody in New Guinea believed Michael
Rockefeller had drowned in 1961.
by interviewing both Dutch and
Indigenous locals Macklin slowly pieced
together the events that led to
Michael's death
and what he learned shocked him to his
very core
in 1957 four years before Michael
arrived in New Guinea a battle between
two rival azmat villagers saw the deaths
of over 100 people in a single day
the Dutch colonists were incensed they
were on a mission to civilize the locals
and 100 murders doesn't exactly scream
High Society Keen to bring them to heal
the Dutch dispatched an armed Patrol one
thing led to another and when the dust
had settled five Warriors from the
village of archenep lay dead from Dutch
gunfire asthmat culture was really into
all that an eye for an eye stuff if a
rival Village killed someone in yours
you had to kill someone in theirs it
wasn't about spite but essential tenet
of their system of spirituality so the
five dead Warriors from Ocean app needed
to be Avenged in order to restore
balance to the world but retaliation
against the Dutch was basically
impossible their guns were so
technologically advanced they may as
well have been magic once however the
Dutch weren't the only people from the
white tribe in New Guinea after retired
and helpless Michael Rockefeller watched
saw an opportunity to avenge their
fallen Brethren Michael was killed
butchered and eaten as payback for
crimes he probably wasn't even aware of
[Music]
Macklin returned to America in April
1969 after four months in New Guinea
he'd seen and heard enough to be
convinced that Michael Rockefeller was
the victim of a cannibalistic killing
he published his findings in a book
called The Search for Michael
Rockefeller it presented a convincing
case but one thing was missing hard
evidence without it doubts would always
remain
over the years the story slowly faded
from the public Consciousness
considering how frankly mental the whole
thing is it's surprising how few people
actually know about it
but the case was reignited in 2014 when
author Carl Huffman published his
research into Michael's disappearance
like Macklin Hoffman traveled to New
Guinea in search of Clues unlike Macklin
Hoffland also paid a visit to the Dutch
Colonial archives in The Hague where he
found a plethora of documents showcasing
that several Dutch officials and
missionaries had suspected Michael's
death at the hands of the ochenep
Headhunters crucially he also discovered
that the Dutch had deliberately
suppressed the truth
as for why Michael's disappearance
occurred during a tumultuous period in
New Guinea's history the doctor in the
process of relinquishing control to
Indonesia and they were Keen to show the
world what a good job they'd done
civilizing the locals revealing that
cannibals had consumed a member of one
of the world's most powerful families
would have been a PR disaster so they
did what all governments do with
embarrassing information they buried it
by the way if you're wondering what the
Rockefellers made of these Revelations
the truth is nobody outside the family
knows publicly they've always stuck to
the official version that Michael
drowned rumors suggest they hired a
private investigator to visit the azmat
in the late 70s whilst he was there he
allegedly traded a boat engine for free
human skulls those of the only white men
the alternate had ever killed whether or
not any of them belonged to Michael is
unknown but supposedly the investigator
was paid a quarter of a million dollars
for smuggling the skulls back to America
so I'll let you draw your own
conclusions
by this point in the video you may
believe it's an open and showcase
Michael Rockefeller was surely killed
and eaten by the azmat however it isn't
quite so simple
consider this all the documented
evidence we have so far can be traced
back to a single Source the azmat
themselves
no Outsiders witnessed Michael's alleged
murder and his remains have never been
found everything we think we know comes
from azmat confessions either made to
the Dutch in the 60s or more recently to
Carl Huffman
it's entirely plausible that the azmat
took credit for the murder to appear
more powerful to Western visitors there
is a second possibility though that the
asthmat came up with the lie to hide an
even more remarkable truth
that's right it's twist time Milt
Macklin returned from New Guinea in the
late 60s with hundreds of hours of
footage documenting his visit the reels
lay untouched and are safe until 2008
when they were recovered by of all
people Charlton heston's son Fraser he
was making a documentary about Macklin's
trip
the reels were a gold mine of
information but it was when Fraser
stumbled upon footage of dozens of
asthmat canoes charging down a river
that he noticed something absolutely
insane
hidden amongst the azmat was a single
naked white guy apparently one of the
tribe could the azmat have come up with
the whole yeah we ate that guy to cover
up the truth that Michael had become one
of them that filmed too grainy for any
serious analysis but you have to admit
the man Bears more than a passing
resemblance to a slightly older Michael
Rockefeller plus if it isn't him who the
hell is it
farfetched as that sounds it's worth
pointing out that almost every
contemporary report from the time of
Michael's death mentions how the
experience transformed him after his
son's disappearance Nelson Rockefeller
even admitted in a TV interview that
Michael had been his happiest during the
Expedition the idea that the heir to one
of the world's richest families gave it
all up to live out his days amongst A
Primitive tribe in a distant land is a
tantalizing possibility could Michael
still be alive to this day even in his
mid-80s
whilst implausible considering he's been
dwelling in the forests of New Guinea
without access to Modern medical care
for so long it's by no means impossible
so then
drowned eaten by sharks eaten by people
or a lost millionaire who went native
you tell me
[Music]
thanks for watching